Yo tengo amigos que suben 150 piezas al
día, ¿vale? Y tienen 200 y 400 millones
de veces que su contenido se ve al mes.
Es decir, 3 billones de impresiones, una
marca personal. Es muy loco lo que está
ocurriendo en español. Yo lo que quiero
decirte es que tú tienes que encontrar
tu estilo de comunicación. ¿Cómo es que
tú vas a crear contenido? No es solo uno
variado. Que si a ti te gusta, por
ejemplo, contar historia, que si a ti te
gusta, por ejemplo, como esta chef que
es increíble, te habla de negocio
cocinando, pero con un arte, una voz y
una música espectacular. Entonces, no lo
traje, pero ya se lo voy a decir. La
tendencia más grande de marketing en
vídeo para el 2026 es la edición, no es
la grabación, no es la calidad del
contenido, es cómo se edita.